as the american president left the white
house for europe there was a stark
answer for one of so many troubling
questions
[Music]
how high is that threat
i think it's a real threat
thank you given the stakes given the
bloodshed perhaps it's a surprise that
the american president has taken this
long to travel to europe to face the
russian threat ahead of him now are
three summits nato the eu and the g7
back to back in one day it is an
unprecedented reflection on the current
state of peace and stability in europe
and here it is spelt out by
propagandists pundits connected to the
kremlin on russian state tv
the thing is who can be sure right now
the leaders of the 30 nato member
countries will be forced to confront
this extraordinary reality when they
meet here in brussels in the hours ahead
the headline will be a remarkable
doubling of the number of nato troops
deployed to eastern europe an
unavoidable reaction to a russian
aggression that is so unpredictable but
how will president putin react is it
perhaps perilously provocative
the alliance's secretary general whose
tenure may now be extended to provide
continuity could not clearly answer the
biggest questions
how does nato defend itself against a
nuclear attack thank you
russia must stop its
nuclear saber rattling
this is dangerous and it is
irresponsible
[Music]
for now the russian attacks on ukraine
remain conventional but devastating
nonetheless these missiles in footage
issued by the russian military
apparently hit ukrainian military
targets sky news is unable to verify the
claim
russia's foreign minister was preempting
nato announcements and on a suggestion
from poland that it could send a
peacekeeping force to ukraine he had
this when
[Music]
this will be that very confrontation
between russian and nato armed forces
that everyone not just wanted to avoid
but said that it should never happen to
begin with
his master president putin told
officials that russia would continue to
supply europe with energy but would
charge in rubles
to shore up the plummeting ruble and
undermine the dollar
there will be pressure at the eu summit
on nations like germany to cut loose
from russian energy but that is so much
easier said than done
so many challenges so many frightening
scenarios and a blunt reality that
nothing the west has done so far has
ended putin's war